what's up guys my name is Colin for the
score eSports you know League of Legends
fans only get two chances a year to
watch major international competition
region against region from incredible
comeback wins - insane solo kills the
midseason Invitational has been a gift
that keeps on giving
speaking of which guys don't forget to
hit that sub button so we can keep on
giving you those sweet sweet email
notifications every time we publish a
new content
now with that out of the way an msi
already underway let's get on with it
with the top ten midseason Invitational
plays of all time kicking off our list
at number 10 is w ease 9:57 who in a 1v3
pulls off the impossible after getting
ambushed by flash wolves 9:57 makes an
incredible play to bob weave and squeeze
through a flurry of attacks stalling
just long enough for his team to take
the three v1 is caught GA I don't think
he's gonna be able to survive this one
there's no support from the restaurant
what about Barrett right now because W
they're running straight for yakaza
is near the Barrett trying to make
are you kidding me at number nine we've
got febiven who's fnatic squad were the
clear underdogs against SK Telecom t1 in
MSI 2015's and semi finals looking to
prove himself against the world's best a
young feather then opened things up with
this sick 1v1
on to faker before doing it again
against the unkillable demon king 2000
go down again against an aggressive pick
making team faker
eats 2 shuriken the knock-up is
interrupted as better than materializes
ignite
[Applause]
style yet as solo cameras division right
now number eight on our list goes to
hooni who in the semi-finals of MSI 2015
found himself in an unfavorable 1v2
against SKT a rookie at the time who
neesh owed the world what he was made of
as he absolutely destroys faker before
finishing off marrin we don't get to get
a chance to revisit you talked about it
playing around
[Applause]
coming in at number seven is Shias
middling Lucien at MSI 2017 after
falling to SKT in the group stage w/e
were looking to rebound in any way
possible
Shia did just that as he got the ball
rolling in Game two with a gutsy tower
dive onto none other than faker Elise
but there's nothing there for points
just straight calling point-blank under
the turret cuts it up early to get the
double shot life steals up with minions
on the way out at number six we've got G
twos perks who after a failed attempt to
steal baron shows us how to get away
with murder as he assassinated two
gigabyte marines players and lived to
tell the tale even with the extra buffs
recently there's no one here to contest
perks can try something as his all deep
from the waters is in it's on the sleigh
should be able to bounce back karate is
gonna take one but that's a one-for-one
here comes the big damage boys
double kill it gets too bad but Ashley
the graves ultimate miss as well
the Great Escape and negating Baron
buffs is really big Vegeta was it hurts
coming in at number five is one of the
most memorable defenses in msi history
after losing the elder drake to TSM g2
were looking to make a cheeky play for
the Nexus but TSM had other plans
Church topside trick is gonna read to
the ocean Drake he's gonna come back for
the next step so I guess my answer is
still there here's the Jimmy tries he
can get back
stop damn
drop set 20 seconds
50-minute 10-15 second death timers and
they go GSM still against the clock it's
gonna be close I think they haven't
at number 4 we have CLG sticks a at MSI
2016 who against RNG showed the world
that he wasn't fazed by playing in his
first international tournament after
losing four of his teammates in a
late-game teamfight stick say avenge
their deaths with this jaw-dropping play
that saw him to leave for RNG players
one after the other this is it this
could be the fight coming in at number
three is Wolf's famous Zyra play on a
team with an abundance of superstars
wolf often takes a backseat to the likes
of faker and bang boom where penguin
parody time Tiago Pico she no more bang
Mooney was one more Ezra Mahajan and a
pen empanada juicy melon fellow
competitor after splitting the first two
games in the 2017 MSI Grand Finals Wolfe
stepped up with an unbelievable play
that helped the Korean legends secure an
MSI title they've got both of them and
now bone Silla leaders are coming
towards the
there's the flat all over the giant
knock I'm gonna find three with the
Earthmen equalizer
one brassiere with never shocked by the
trade only honest importance that not
going to make it much longer as well the
chase is it look at this beautiful plays
out of faith
by in some applause
look at this game they think quiz
spotting the guys coming from the side
Oh wolf get all three members both of
the primary carries absolutely
annihilated before faker even gets there
Mooney had a great equalizer on top of
the Lions there that was just beautiful
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
none other than s K T's bang in arguably
one of the best matches of MSI 2015 SKT
and fnatic went back and forth in a
series of dramatic events that left fans
on the edge of their seats but there was
perhaps nothing more exhilarating than
bangs pentakill that put an end to the
game with style are they gonna go oh who
didn't quite get to bang meanwhile wolf
comes back of the head before Christ
granny Kaiser comes out and rein over
training of the back lines of dingy
where the big absolute zero Martin is
huge literally because that wild growth
booty manages to catch Baker with his
ultimate a faker
in big trouble of doubles guilt-free
buddy ready hey Kent triple kill SK
Telecom
[Applause]
coming in at number one on our list is a
team play for the ages it's CLG at MSI
2016 going into a crucial teamfight CLG
were down 15k gold against an undefeated
rng can they do it does get Monta the
dragon goes down it's secured by you
believe don't you have the faith in CLG
because they just secured three looking
for it then can the end on this one look
at this Jayden's play holy crap smithy
alright so they make the call we're
going for the teamfight only guys aren't
you are focused on the objective and
this pickup table smitten against the
don't zoom in on the dragon to keep it
alive they take down the two people then
who he pushes them off of the Lancers
fight Bluebird gets stuck in this dragon
pit look at he can't even move with his
ear wall there he's stuck and they just
separate the team and clean up that
fight oh my god
orangey are tilting after that genius
playing from CLG with a single teamfight
CLG would go on to take baron setting
themselves up for a win that fell
nothing short of magical Nexus turret
will fall another will fall 42 minutes
well guys that's our list and with SK
Telecom t1 not attending Hema side for
the first time ever who do you think
will win let me know in the comments
below and I will see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button